how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel
and everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
and today we have a very interesting
discovery a discovery that connects the
previous
infinity saga way back in the beginning
of the infinity saga to
the future of the marvel cinematic
universe we know that with phase four
phase five and everything else that's
coming to the mc we are going to get a
ton of new characters we're going to get
some new avengers we're going to get
some new
villains and we're going to get the
x-men and the fantastic four
and we all know how marvel works in fact
we know they love to plant seeds
years and years in advance and it seems
like we found one of those seeds today
a seed that connects iron man tony stark
to the x-men
and the fantastic four who we know are
going to be coming relatively soon
because kevin feige announced them at
2019's san diego comic-con and in this
video i'm going to talk about how tony
stark
probably already had contact with some
of the x-men and some of the fantastic
four
even way before avengers age of ultron
and how tony stark is still going to
have
a major impact on the mcu moving forward
i'll break it all down but first if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a mysterio
funko pop just subscribe like the video
and leave a comment down below to enter
so to start off with how tony stark knew
about all of these other
superheroes and super groups we have to
take a look at this
recently discovered easter egg all the
way back in iron man 2.
in the scene in iron man 2 when tony
stark pulls out his phone if you take a
very close look at some of the apps on
his phone
you can see that one of them says
illuminati
now this is a massive discovery
if you have been following my channel
for a bit you probably know who the
illuminati are
in fact we've had several reports
stating that the illuminati are going to
be coming to the mcu quite soon
in fact friend of the channel mikey
sutton broke the first scoop
about the illuminati coming to the mcu
and he said that we could see them as
early on
as doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
now if you don't know who the illuminati
are i'll do a quick breakdown so you
know how important this is for the
future of the mcu
the illuminati is a secret organization
comprised of
several of the world's most powerful
superheroes
it was formed by tony stark and the
group consists of
tony stark himself the sorcerer supreme
doctor strange
black bolt the king of the inhumans
charles xavier the founder of the x-men
namor the submariner and king of
atlantis
and reed richards the founding member of
the fantastic
four now this group was formed in secret
to protect
the world the group would meet and they
would share information
and decide secretly how each and every
one of their individual groups would
correspond to threats
so it's basically the uniting of the
leaders of each individual superhero
group
the avengers the fantastic four the
x-men the inhumans etc
and now we have discovered this easter
egg for the illuminati all the way back
in iron man 2.
does this mean that tony stark was
already trying to form the illuminati
way back in iron man 2.
well it seems to be that way and i'll
tell you how it could have happened and
how it will lead to the illuminati
forming
in phase 4 phase 5 or somewhere in the
future
so as we look at this phone we see the
illuminati app and we also see the
shield
app but the thing about tony stark is
that he's never really trusted people
especially the government to be able to
take care of things which is why he
never gives them access to his iron man
suits and he shares that lack of trust
with nick fury nick fury doesn't exactly
trust people either
and we know thanks to a deleted scene
from the very first iron man film that
nick fury told
iron man about mutants as if gamma
accidents
radioactive bug bites and assorted
mutants weren't enough
i have to deal with a spoiled brat who
doesn't play well with others and wants
to keep all his toys to himself
who the hell are you nick fury
director of shield so tony was well
aware of
mutants he was also made aware of
spider-man when nick fury said
radioactive bug bites and it's more than
likely that he tried to track some of
these people down
if not out of pure curiosity and we
actually know for a fact that he did
track at least some of these people down
because of captain america
civil war nick fury mentioned
radioactive
bug bites that is spider-man and when
tony stark needed
additional backup in captain america
civil war who did he go get
he got peter parker aka spider-man and
he knew about spider-man because
nick fury already told him about him and
tony stark has the greatest technology
that the world has ever seen with the
exception of wakandan technology so for
tony stark to track down some mutants
and fantastic four members it probably
wasn't that hard and tony stark wanted
to track down some of these members
because he wanted to form his own team
the illuminati after the events of iron
man 1 and after the events and the
government's involvement with the
incredible hulk tony
stark predicted the future he predicted
that the government would want to
control
all of these new super people and he
also predicted that the government
wouldn't be enough to stop
many of the future threats that were to
come so just like in the comics tony
stark decided
to take it all into his own hands and he
began to search for these other groups
of super people that way he could form
his own council
and take care of the threats of the
world himself alongside of these people
in fact it could have even been nick
fury himself that encouraged him to go
and seek these other groups out because
again nick fury doesn't exactly trust
people either
and for good measure because we saw what
the government was going to do
in the first avengers film they were
going to nuke new york city
they were going to kill millions of
people because they couldn't handle the
threat of an
alien invasion and we knew tony stark
was pretty serious about the illuminati
before because he had an
app on his phone for it but he
definitely got even more serious after
the events of the avengers
now tony stark most likely found some of
these people but
after the events of the avengers he
decided to take the world security into
his own hands
and we know this because tony tried to
make ultron and he wanted a suit of
armor everywhere around the world for
the world security
what if the lord was safe what if next
time
aliens roll up to the club and they will
they couldn't get past the bouncer
i see a suit of armor around the world
sounds like a cold world tony
i've seen colder and he made sure to
bring that back up to captain america in
avengers end game
that what we needed was a pseudo armor
around the world remember that
whether it impacted our precious
freedoms or not that's what we
needed so tony knew that eventually
there would be some sort of an attack on
earth
from space and they did come and
ultimately it would be tony who ended up
paying the ultimate sacrifice to defeat
that threat and now sadly he's gone he
didn't have the illuminati at the time
or the suit of armor around the world
however now it is very clear that
threats like
thanos and future threats like galactus
are not going to be able to be beaten
by the government the only way to beat
these future threats is
if all of the superheroes come together
all of the different groups the avengers
the x-men the fantastic four and any
other superheroes out there
and they'll need leaders to coordinate
what they're all going to do together
and this is where tony stark's plans
that he had for the illuminati will
finally come back and finally happen
an elite superhero group that controls
all of the superhero groups around the
world
making sure all of these groups are
working together to stop
all of the threats and ultimately they
are going to all need to come together
it's highly speculated that the next
huge event that marvel is going to have
in the next eight to ten years is going
to be avengers
secret wars battle world where all of
the teams come together the x-men the
fantastic four
the avengers the inhumans and even some
villains
all come together and now it's only a
matter of time until we actually see
this on screen but all of these groups
coming together is going to start with
the illuminati
now again tony stark already had plans
for the illuminati he had the app on his
phone
but now it's going to have to fall into
somebody else's hands and that person
will most likely be
dr strange he's an original member of
the illuminati in the comics and he has
a connection to the avengers in the mcu
and will most likely have a connection
to the x-men and the fantastic four so
it seems like marvel has been planning
this for a very
long time planning an easter egg for the
illuminati in iron man 2.
what do you think about this let me know
your thoughts about the illuminati being
set up all the way back
in phase 1 of the marvel cinematic
universe and let me know how excited you
are to finally see the illuminati form
and the x-men of the fantastic four come
into the mcu let me know what you think
in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel cinematic universe
news for live updates you can follow me
on twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof